in this video i'm going to talk about
reactive oxygen species or ross
and how ross is generated and what is
the effect of ross in our body
especially the harmful effect of ross
so what are reactive oxygen species so
as we know for our life oxygen is really
important
but
this oxygen
and some species of this oxygen could be
very harmful
one of such species of oxygen is
reactive oxygen species
are called
ross
and ross are actually chemically
reactive molecules which have oxygen so
these are chemically reactive molecules
containing oxygen
such ross are peroxide superoxide and
hydroxyl radical so we would discuss
them step by step so here here is oxygen
and this oxygen once reduced by gaining
one electron it would form a superoxide
radical and superoxide radical is super
duper dangerous
so
this is the basic structure of
oxygen molecule
and after
reduction
it would gain one electron
and it would form
a reactive oxygen species as you can see
this is the stable structure of the
oxygen molecule but when it gains an
extra electron
it is unstable so in order to gain
stability
it would try to donate the electron to
others and make
other molecule reactive
so in this respect
this oxygen
uh plus one electron which is actually
superoxide radical is very dangerous
other super other
such
reactive oxygen species are
hydrogen peroxide hydrogen peroxide is
not as dangerous as superoxide radical
but still it has a lot of harmful effect
apart from hydrogen peroxide
another super duper dangerous
reactive oxygen species is hydroxyl
radical and hydroxyl radical have plenty
of
harmful effects on our body
and the enzymatic defense system which
actually combat ross cannot combat this
hydrogen peroxide this uh this hydroxyl
radical
so basically we need antioxidant to
combat this hydrogen this hydroxyl
radical
so ultimate ultimately what happens
ultimately what happens our body
converts most of these ross into our non
harmful state so if
the most harmful
species of ross is super oxide
superoxide getting converted to hydrogen
peroxide then hydrogen peroxide could be
formed
to
could be formed to water or it could be
partially reduced
to hydroxyl
radical so hydroxyl radical is pretty
harmful
now we would see how ross is generated
and there are basically two source of
ros generation one is exogenous and one
is endogenous so let's first discuss the
endogenous pathway of ros generation
so ross is generated normally in our
body
during
oxidative phosphorylation
the complex four in complex four
uh the terminal electron acceptor is
oxygen so oxygen accepts four electron
and form two molecules of water
now instead of accepting four electron
if oxygen molecule accepts uh one
electron then it would convert it into a
superoxide radical so during a normal
process in our body some amount of ross
could be generated
other steps like
during respiratory bursts by macrophages
ross is also generated so let's say our
body is invaded by a pathogen these
red-colored bacterias
so our
macrophage and dendritic cell would take
up those bacteria so inside the
macrophage those bacterias have to be
killed and
these macrophages kill these bacteria by
means of ross so in that respect ross is
also generated and let's say we have a
inflammatory sensation now during
inflammation ross is also generated so
basically we have seen there are mainly
three type of ways how endogenous ros
could be generated
let's see the exogenous
pathway
so the in exogenous pathway
the by ionizing radiation such as
uv radiation
can
damage our body and can produce a lot of
ross
and uv radiation particularly have a lot
of
harmful effects on our body and we will
discuss it later
apart from uv radiation tobacco smoke
like drugs and genobiotics
and due to pollution ross could be also
generated not only pollution
by application of pesticides
by application of pesticides and
consuming uh
food affected food and vegetables
affected by pesticides ross could be
generated in our body one such example
is rotenon which is actually a
component of pesticide but it could
generate ross when it's
consumed when rotten on treated plants
are consumed
so let's see
what are the harmful effects of ross in
our body
so ross is very harmful
and
first harmful effect of ross
first most harmful effect of ross is
lipid peroxidation so here you can see
a plasma membrane a plus a plasma
membrane bilayer a lipid bilayer
and here we have drawn a hydroxyl
radical and hydroxyl radical has one
electron extra so it can
it want to gain stability and it can
donate its electron to a nearby
lipid molecule of the
bilayer lipid bilayer and then what
happens
this particular
lipid molecule
get reactive
then it
uh
transfers it electron to the nearby and
then a chain reaction kind of thing
takes place
and as a result
uh there is a potential damage in the
cell membrane so and cell membrane is
very important for functionality of the
cell
any damage in the cell membrane could
cause osmolarity disbalance and when
there is a osmoritic disbalance cell
there is a high chance that cell could
be lysed
ross could have harmful effect on
proteins ross could attack proteins and
ross could actually oxidize
but ross could actually reduce or
oxidize particularly
specific groups inside the protein one
such example is ross could convert the
sulfhydryl group
into
actually oxidize the sulfhydryl group of
gaba dh and enzyme
and
sulfhydryl group in gap dh is really
essential for the function of that
particular enzyme and by
uh
this action
ross is able to
or
ross is actually able to reduce the
functionality of that particular enzyme
not only enzymes many signaling
molecules many other structural proteins
like collagen
they are already harmed by these raws
ross can have potentially damaging
effect on dna
like this hydroxyl radical it could
affect the dna and it could cause a
mutation and if this mutation is not
repaired
or
this
this
mutation is not repaired there is a
chance that
it could be
and if this mutation is in the genome
cell then it could be
segregated to uh next and next
generation
and which could be potentially harmful
and
it could be damaging and
apart from that this dna damage
could lead to apoptosis also so ross
mediated dna damage could ultimately
lead to apoptosis
let's come to neurons
ross could damage the myelin sheath of
the neurons as you can see in this
neuron the myelin sheath of the neuron
is potentially damaged by the ross
thus rocks can reduce
the
velocity of action potential
transmission and thereby it could
reduce and it could decrease the
neuronal functionality
so when there is a
increase of ross
neurodege risk of neurodegeneration also
increases and it is a
highly classified research topic in
these days
apart from neuron
ross can also have damaging effect on
mitochondria
if ross actually
uh
cause damage into the mitochondrial
membrane then there is a chance that
cytochrome c would be leaked out into
the cytoplasm and once cytochrome c is
licked into the cytoplasm cytochrome c
could activate apoph1
and other
and these above one cytochrome c
complex can actually activate other
caspases
and there is a space cascade would go on
and ultimate fate would be the
cell death program cell death by
apoptosis so here are some
uh harmful effect of raws apart from
these ross is
mainly
ross is a main cause of aging and ross
can cause multiple type of disease
so in these days
these days a huge research on ross is
going on and scientists have identified
that ross could be
the cause of many diseases
so
ross and
its harmful effect is
really essential to study these days
and
it was all about ross
and i hope you enjoyed the video
and if you like my video please give it
a quick thumbs up
please share
and don't forget to subscribe
thank you